mir jetzt zugeschaltet barbara breuer
die sprecherin der berliner stadtmission
wir haben gerade schon gesehen wie
momentan die situation ist natürlich die
korona krise ist auch für die
obdachlosen nicht einfach was ist jetzt
das schwerste in dieser zeit für die ich
denke für die menschen ist es ganz ganz
schwer auf der straße den ganzen tag
unterwegs zu sein und dann keinen platz
zu haben wo sie sich mal kurz
niederlassen und ausruhen können das
klang gerade in dem beitrag auch schon
an also beispielsweise in der
bahnhofsmission haben über 50 bis 60
leute tagsüber reingelassen im
stundentakt die konnten dann kaffee
trinken und in ruhe eine zeitung lesen
sich miteinander unterhalten
selbst auf der straße gibt es soziale
kontakte auch wenn die leute einzeln
unterwegs sind können sie sich natürlich
vom sehen und reden dann gerne
miteinander und das alles führt zu einer
richtigen vereinsamung und auch dieses
gefühl einfach nur noch auf der straße
abgefertigt zu werden am fenster das
brennt sich bei den menschen ein und
führte zur verzweiflung
wenn wir gerade dass sie gehen dem
zentrum auch gesehen hier gehe jetzt vor
einem kommunen zeiten besonders wichtig
es gibt viele maßnahmen schutzmaßnahmen
vor allem war wie sehr können die jetzt
überhaupt eingehalten werden also in der
korona hochzeit haben wir unser bestes
getan um da alles möglich zu machen der
kältebus ist beispielsweise durch berlin
gefahren und hat den menschen per
kanister die möglichkeit geboten sich
dort die hände open air zu waschen und
masken guten verteilt von der berliner
stadtmission wir nehmen die auch selber
also jeder der bei uns einem und maske
haben möchte bekommt die auch in den
notunterkünften wird fieber gemessen da
wurden die menschen in essens gruppen
eingeteilt auch da sind wir natürlich
bemüht die hygiene standards einzuhalten
ist halt nicht immer ganz einfach
vielen dank barbara breuer für diese
einblicke dankeschön
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren